rené lamballe info-social morelia à ce
moment vous vous trouvez à la centrale
info-santé info social de montréal plus
précisément au sein de l'équipe
info social madame vous sentez comment
un peu un état de détresse des
témoignages de détresse et d'angoise
c'est le quotidien des travailleurs
sociaux de la ligne impôt social mais
l'aco vide a fait exploser le nombre
d'appels à l'aide dans la première vague
l'on pouvait avoir constamment 100-150
appel en attente avec des temps
d'attentes qui pouvait dépasser une
heure facilement l'année passée au même
moment on répondait à 90 % des appels en
quatre minutes on risque est plus le cas
aujourd'hui même pas du tout non au
sommet de la première vague en mai les
travailleurs sociaux ont répondu à plus
de 3000 appels
c'est deux fois plus qu'à la même
période l'an passé plus du tiers était
directement lié à la qu'ovide après une
certaine accalmie cet été le retour à
des mesures sanitaires plus strict à
propulser le nombre d'appels vers des
records du nombre d'appels en septembre
encore une fois deux fois plus que
l'année dernière
l' angoisse face à la pandémie ne
s'estompe pas la détresse a cependant
évolué entre les deux vagues d'oise a
fait la première vague aimait beaucoup
de la plaque qui communiquer avec nous
parce qu'il vivait un stress un stress
lié à l'avènement du cobp et d'avoir
peur de se faire infecter en ce moment
ce qui revient beaucoup sait déjà qu'ils
ont de la difficulté en termes
d'adaptation sociale en lien avec les
mesures center ce stress lié à l'usure
se traduit dans les résultats
préliminaires de l'étude d'un groupe de
chercheurs qui tentent d'évaluer le
niveau de bien être actuel des québécois
comparativement 2012 ouvre santé de la
population qui avait une santé mentale
optimale était de 67 points 5 % leur
notre échantillon montre que ce taux a
baissé à peu près 40 8%
la chercheure georgie havre ac as croit
que les nombreux changements aux règles
sanitaires en vigueur contribuer à
l'anxiété collective
l'être humain a besoin de savoir où on
s'en va on a le droit de sortir un jour
le lendemain on peut pas la teneur des
messages transmis dans les conférences
de presse n'aide pas non plus au moral
des québécois elle milite pour que le
gouvernement fasse preuve d'une plus
grande transparence
le problème aussi c'est quand ça arrive
qu'il n'y a pas de justification claire
info social à la centrale de 8 à 1 ce
n'est donc pas des zones oranges ou
rouges dont on s'inquiète et bien des
zones grises face à l'inconnu et à
l'incertitude ici valérie gamache radio
canada québec